I actually struggle to read um I have
ADHD and so paying attention to books
has actually been very difficult
everybody thinks I'm like this big
reader that reads hundreds of books a
year I don't um I've written more books
than I'd read um uh uh but I do like
learning and so the way I learn is from
listening so conversations with people
who are smarter than me being being that
student um always having a student
mindset and S will be curious about what
makes other people tick um so uh
insatiable curiosity in conversations
but I like documentaries as well
um and so two documentaries that I would
recommend which are fantastic for sort
of leadership education um one of them
is Senna Senna which is about race car
driver in Senate even if you're not into
Formula 1 racing it's still a brilliant
documentary it's still very enjoyable
but basically it highlights these two
archetypes Senna who drives for passion
and Alan Prost who drives for the
numbers you know and if you compare that
to our Martin day you know who's driven
by the end ofe goal the quarterly goal
at you know at any cost versus who's the
person who does it for the love and you
start to see how they command sener
commands tremendous love and loyalty
from the other drivers who are competing
against him but they support him where
nobody likes Prost and you just it you
start to see these two archetypes it ask
you know it's asked the simple question
who do you want to be what kind of Life
do you want to live um do you want to
live one of passion or one obsessed with
numbers um and it's just it puts it out
there yeah the other one is kumare k m a
r e yeah it's it wasn't supposed to be a
leadership documentary but it ends up
being a great leadership documentary of
a a documentarian who sets out to sort
of mock the sort of Guru culture I won't
give anything away no spoilers here but
let's just say something goes wrong okay
and uh and it it's actually quite
interesting